jasmine is my soulmate and i haven't
even met her yet but to be honest she's
out of my league
i kind of have a wild side and now i'm
flying to tunisia to marry someone i've
never met in person
selena and i have a deep connection but
i'm worried what other people would say
is a massive difference between us
[Applause]
wow that's a very beautiful hair
i'm so excited for him to get here but i
am a little worried that johnny may not
like me when he sees me in person
i flew halfway across the road to meet
the man of my dreams i messaged him and
he messaged me back and i was like oh my
god and that's how i fell in love with
international superstar usman aka soulja
boy
[Music]
i've spent 34 years looking for the love
of my life and i've found that in jimena
there's nothing that's going to stop me
from proposing on this trip
there's a lot you don't know about a
person if you've only been speaking
online what's the password what's the
password
give me your password
despite the 28-year age difference we
have jesus in common the lord is
blessing this relationship have you guys
video chatted at all
uh no she's just very shy
this is not ella
i want to talk about prenuptial
agreement
if you do not sign i do not want to
marry you
[Music]
somewhere in this airport i'm scared
he's gonna see me in the wheelchair he's
gonna go ew
why would you bring me here shoot a
video about another woman this is funny
are you too funny very funny
funny too
were you texting with her
yes or no
i think i made a big mistake i hate you
because you broke my heart
i thought it was real
it's like a switch change
my mind's going crazy
[Music]
you